[Music]
so if you had a long day at work you're
feeling absolutely crappy and stressed
out well nikka has the solution for you
she's going to show you a really simple
and gentle evening yoga sequence which
will help you to be stressed whine down
and also sleep better yes definitely
been a long day we're going to practice
very simple yoga sequence will take you
maybe 10 or 15 minutes and then we're
going to finish it with a simple
breathing technique to also help you
fall asleep faster let's do it let's do
it you're going to start sitting
straight on our mat keep your legs
crossed
okay keep your back straight close your
eyes and relax your shoulders make sure
your spine is straight you let the
relaxed and start breathing deeply three
[Music]
dear Evan and jazz yes hello
my guy inhale jeez
[Music]
next henna
just keep reading for your nose
allowing any tension in your body to
slowly melt away as you act hello
[Music]
[Music]
inhale again and as you exhale slowly
drop your chin down to with your chest
just rotate your head B you're using any
tension in your neck one the time-being
circle slowly straighten your hair okay
when your palms and your shoulders
they're going to just gently roll to the
back a lot of us hands all day sitting
in front of a computer and the tension
in the shoulders you might feel at the
end of the day this is a great simple
excess just release it you can just roll
all the way forward as well
gently breathing black one more and then
slowly bring your hands all the way with
you as you exhale bring your left arm
down right and go to the side stretch
open up your chest and if you don't get
aside inhale up and as you exhale go to
the other side inhale let's lift all the
way up and we saw it's fine again
releasing any tension to the left over
your left shoulder
[Music]
and then to the right over your right
shoe and then slowly forward we are
going to release our leg okay from here
gently go into your plank pose you can
see breath in as you exhale drop your
knees down and we are going to go into a
simple over lay down all the way pumps
next to your chest with inhale you can
do this stuff here if you have more of a
bunch turn you can lift all the way up
into a higher Cobra okay I'm just really
feel free to be here and just letting it
find and
your bra okay releasing any tension in
the lower back secretly breath in some
people call it a bank phone a baby Cobra
you can be present as you exhale slowly
release and we are going to bring our
palms behind interlace our fingers and
with inhale lift all the way up into the
half locust pose
just keep stretching all the way really
lifting the chest and releasing any
tension you should one more as you
exhale slowly bring your palms next to
your chest you can slowly throw all the
way to the core again as you exhale tuck
in YouTube let's go into your downward
facing dog
here breathing deeply here done with us
a really great stretch for the whole
body again to relieve any tension
[Music]
with your next inhale bring your left
leg all the way up objects are we going
to swing them like all people and do the
easy pigeon so just bend your leg to the
side drop it down and bring your palm
now inhale lift all the way open up your
chest as you exhale gently crawl your
palm all the way forward for head down
to the girl it will help you to open up
your hips a little bit release any
tension especially if you've been
sitting the whole day just open it up
breathe into that chip nice long deep
breath one more
[Music]
and then slowly bring you both pumps
next to your knees inhale lift all rep
roll up your spine when I do exhale
gently go down into your damn down stick
one with deep breath in and bring your
right leg up as you exhale swing it all
the way school it sit down make sure you
stay in the center there's always
tendency to sort of go to this by little
bit thinner Center inhale open up your
chest and as you exhale go forward
forehead down to the ground and again
relax no pushing just allow you have to
open one lucky breath in and then jab
[Music]
and again bring your palms back next to
your knee inhale lift it all the way up
see prison open chest as you exhale go
down into your dominating couple of deep
breaths here
just relax in your downward dog stretch
all the muscles and then slowly drop
your knees down and we're going to sit
down and extend our legs forward sit up
straight and we're going to bring the
right foot and the left in a tie with
inhale reach your hands all the way up
as you exhale fold all the way forward
next when you're falling forward
remember not to it's not a competition
maybe choose who's there at a lot of us
try to do this and reparative you just
gently want to fall forward first from
the octonal
band from the chest and then your
forehead goes down all right if your
hamstrings are pretty tight again also
if you like a little bit better and go
down no pushing just allowing your
breath to guide you here take one with
you breath and exhale with your next
inhale it is all up and as you exhale
we're going to gently twist to the right
right thumb goes down left hand on your
knees look over your right shoulder
make sure you think straight and not
lifting your left side and breathe
gentle twist and that is Sudi for us and
one keep that right calm down now we're
in time you're going to lift your left
hand up lift your heads up and gently if
your whole body and stretch I love this
stretch it just opens up the whole body
make just make this fine to feel like
the Breslin
and as you asked hello gently go down
good let's change the side right like
your forward left foot on the right in a
tie with inhale bring your hands all the
way up as you exhale I get Jam equals oh
don't worry about touching the same nice
grounding breath lengthening your body
stretching it out letting go of any
tension as you inhale it missed all the
way and as you exhale twist to the left
left I'm down to the ground ride on your
knee and look over your left shoulder
3dc by twisting you also help you
digestive system a little bit there just
your dinner before you and again keep
that last bum down on the ground passed
down and right hand goes up with inhale
lift your heads up gently stretch all
the way to the back does it feel good
yeah oh whatever in my lower back school
yeah it's really great for a little bit
as you exhale slowly risen go from here
we're going to bring your ball feet
together sitting straight this is our
little butterfly pose inhale lift your
head up lengthen spine exhale again
gently fold forward again don't worry
about touching your forehead to your
toes not about that just lengthen the
spine
open the hip let it stretch out and you
needs any tension
as you inhale let's lift all the way and
you're like oh wait from here one
vertebra at a time without collapsing a
lot of us will just straight away go
down slowly one vertebrae at a time
we're going to roll all the way down
from here just gently bring your knees
to the chest give it a nice squeeze
maybe roll a little bit from side to
side and then you're going to lift your
legs up you can actually do this laughs
hot in bed okay because there is a very
high chance you might actually fall
asleep at the end of it you might as
well be in bed already and if you have a
wall you can lift your legs up up the
wall and let it let you're like resting
for a while okay you allow the whole
blood to flow down and really relax your
whole body you can just keep your legs
up here keep breathing you can release
your palms down or support your legs if
your abdominal muscles another strong
another option for you here would be to
just go into a shoulder set or calipers
which basically will bring you would
bring your legs above your head and
gently lift all the way up for those of
you have been practicing yoga this would
be an option a little bit more advanced
option to get the same benefit of just
blood rushing down till it's your heart
okay and you can also take it from there
and maybe go into a plow pose which is
really really grounding brandy and he's
keeping it soft I'm just dropping the
legs above your head okay you don't have
to have your knees straight it can be
banned you can even touch your knees to
the forehead there's just something
really relaxing and grounding about this
pose and then slowly as you exhale again
one vertebra at a time
can roll your spine out again this is
funky I mean all you can do that I can
stay with legs up the wall for as long
as you want and then when you are ready
drop your knees down to your chest give
it a sweep and you're going to finish
with a happy baby pose play slow to
bring any support hands in the middle
and grab hold and all the outer edges of
your feet and from here I'm going to
just gently roll up on some sides I like
a happy baby okay
this massage is fine relaxing one more
and then slowly this okay bring your
left leg down as always you're going to
finish with a simple spinal twist right
it goes over to the left side right hand
resting on the floor make sure your
shoulder stays down nice gentle spin
until again and gently exhale out in the
center change the side left me guess
your chest and over to the right side
left hand extending shoulder down nice
gentle twist one more time inhale deeply
back to the center as you exhale release
your both legs down you're going to go
to shavasana everybody's favorite food
when you just get to relax and maybe
you're already in your bed we are going
to practice simple breathing technique
to help you sleep faster okay so just
start with right down on the floor and
when you awkward
Pete as well take a deep breath in
through your nose gently exhale out
and before we practice our relaxing
breath I'd like you to take a moment to
reflect on your day try to think about
one specific thing you're grateful for
today
allow the positive energy of gratitude
to fill your whole body and now we're
going to move on to practice our
breathing technique it's called four
seven eight technique when you're going
to inhale for a count of four you're
going to hold your breath for the count
of seven
and then exhale for the count of eight
okay so the speed doesn't really matter
is just the ratio this matter is closed
so just close your eyes and slow exhale
oh and then in healthy people one two
three four
hold your breath one two three four five
six seven
and exhale one two three four five six
seven eight and again inhale DC 1 2 3 4
hold 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
exhale 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and this is one
with time inhale 1 2 3 or halt the
breath 1 2 3 4 5 6
and exhale one two three all five six
seven and go back to normal breathing
whole body relax your mind is calm
[Music]
slowly drifting away tonight
[Music]
you did a policy when you still with us
you can gently move your toes and
fingers bringing awareness back to your
body slowly bring your legs together
bring your hands over your head stretch
and slowly bring your knees to your
chest please and just squeeze tonight
you're going to slowly roll all the way
relax
they start yes falling asleep now
alright so if you ever struggle you know
to fall asleep you've ever struggled to
climb down this is something you can do
on a daily basis every night
definitely such a short sequence and as
I said you can do a part of it when
you're lying down on the floor in bed so
the transition to sleep is just English
yes if you enjoyed this workout do check
out more of my car yoga's workout right
here she has a morning sequence as well
to keep you energized gosh I am so calm
right now I just wanna relax and fall
asleep so thank you so much guys be sure
to subscribe to this channel we will be
sharing a lot more videos like this
video and share with your friends as
well thank you so much for watching and
we'll see you on the mat next time good
night sweet dreams